right this way guys
you live in mainland China yes okay do
you bring anything from China to the
United States no you have a good day
thank you how you doing good
what's the purpose of your trip
just for fun
what'd you do out there
go hang out
all right just wait over there for me
I noticed that he was very blunt and I
asked him why did he go to the Dominican
Republic which is a source country for
Narcotics and he just quickly said I
just wanted to have fun so I want to
talk more to him and engage more in the
conversation with
him he's got two bags so he's good all
right
he's about yours yep let's double check
all right follow us this way
all right so sir we got a lot of
questions for you first of all are all
these your bags in front of you when did
you pack your bags
that's nice this morning
all right you packed it by yourself yeah
all right did anybody give you anything
to bring that's all mine I mean all this
is my my my family sent me yes
take a step back
so why did you go to Dominican Republic
I just wanted to see a friend it was her
birthday and uh we were just spending
day the weekend
how many days
Thursday Friday
a lot of stuff to take for just four
days or so
why all the cookware
you bought this down there no I could
move here so my mom came in the summer
you're done and she realized that I
don't have that much stuff that I had
before so your mom gave this to you in
San Domingo no my mom gave it to my
friend to bring it to me oh she gave it
to your friend okay
foreign
onion shampoo
is that for you
it was probably he was probably here as
I said that uh we got to Santo Domingo
at night she had all the stuff in the in
her bag and we just put everything here
do you use the shampoo I don't you don't
use it no okay what's wrong with the
shampoo not too many people come back
with two bottles of shampoo when they go
on a four day trip
it's a good concealment method for Ohio
narcotics and shampoo bottles
they figure we're not going to get our
hands dirty and show a thorough check
let's get the Gemini for me we'll do a
test on it
[Music]